Is this on? Is this all right? Here we
go. Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast for gay Monday?
Yes.
October.
What's Today the 28th 29th the 30th it's
going to be the 30th this is my first
live. Whenever I'm sitting
on, I'm at the very best.
Very metro sexual couch.
This looks like a lot of guys blue.
Other guys on this thing.
This is,
this is sort of the reverse w hotel.
The way they have this
thing like the w hotel.
It just looks like everything's been just
on and that a bunch of Yolo Douche has
had a threesome.
There is something this looks like.
Is there like a gay chain of hotels
that just caters to gay people?
You don't see.
This is why this is going to be weird
with the live crowd because to me that was
no big deal. Everybody got
real quiet. They're like,
it's like that was a problem.
Is he trashing gay people or why is he
saying that there should be segregated
hotels? No, I am not. Okay.
I'm just saying that it would be nice
if you could separate them from the
general population in the hotels.
Okay. That's what I'm running on.
I'm going to out hate Trump and fucking,
whenever the next stupid election is
going to be, I'm going to out hate him.
I'm just going to start calling him a
pussy and I'm just going to fucking,
I'm going to hate even more than him.
Then I'm going to get elected and then
I'll tear down whatever part of the wall
he made,
which I know is a hot button
issue here in Arizona. Oh yeah.
They should have the wall. Oh,
they should. They shouldn't. Um,
that's what I would run on a platform.
I would run on a platform that gay
people should have their own hotels.
I'm so sick of walking into lobby,
seeing men holding hands with other men,
and it just started off on
something bizarre like that,
just so I can watch my opponent going,
wait a minute,
I never even thought about hating this.
You know,
why won't Hillary Clinton go away?
Why can't you just understand
that nobody likes her?
She just fucking hanging around just
like that fucking kid who just shows up
like nobody tells her there's a party
and then she shows up. You know,
you know what happened with her and no
one ever poured blood on her in a fucking
prom. That's what they should have
done to finally fucking get rid of her.
You know, she just keeps hanging
around like she's a winner. You know?
Did Jim Kelly hang around after losing
four fucking super bowls? He didn't.
He fucking disappeared.
And every once in a while in NFL crew
finds the fucking guy and goes, hey Jim,
let's talk about your career. Yeah, I
don't want it. I really don't want him.
I did have a great career, but all
you want to dwell on is the negative.
Oh my God. She says she's just, I mean she
tries to, you know, she's gonna fucking,
she's going to take volume.
You still can't hear it
louder. What? All right,
this was the dumbest for you guys
listening at home who can hear this?
Totally fine.
There's like 500 people staring
at me right now bitching
that they can't hear it.
So I'm holding a microphone with a yellow
windscreen and a little fucking lapel,
Mike. All right. As far as I can tell,
only the foreigners for some reason,
can't fucking hear me. Everybody
has some sort of Australian x six
fucking people. Foreign
is coming their way. Look,
the fuck did you come here for to
tell us how fucked up our country is.
I love when people come here and they can,
they start bitching about this
country. It's just like, dude,
I don't do that when I go to Australia.
Talking about how fucked up your
country is that only around the edges?
Is it livable?
It's fucking unbelievable.
If you can't see the ocean, you just
completely, you're in no man's land.
No Man's land. 200 the most
poisonous fucking snakes ever.
Do I say that when I go to Australia?
No, I don't. I just go, oh,
look at the surf. Oh my God. It's
gorgeous. Absolutely beautiful.
Look at that sad Tanguy
blowing into that giant horn.
I bet he used to own this view way back
in the day. He bet his ancestors did.
What is the, what is the call
on that? You know what I mean?
I never understand that. When I was
in fucking Canada, the rule was they,
what did they say? Like I ice, I
called them the, uh, the natives,
the natives of, of Canada, and they
got all fucking offended. They said,
we're called the originals,
the original everything with Canada's,
the original six, the original
people, you know what I mean?
The original recipe of whatever fucking
syrup they're trying to sell you.
You know what I mean? John?
Everybody loves Canada.
Like they're a bunch of friendly people.
They're not,
they're all a bunch of fucking racist
sticky people and they're in a bad mood
from gag in that SAP out of the fucking
trees. And then what do they do?
They kick all the indigenous people
all the way up north, you know,
to give him a perimeter between them and
the polar bears. That's what happened.
You know, you ever see any of these
big Hollywood types talking about them?
Meryl Streep, you know,
I dunno, I picked her.
I'm still pissed at her that she said
the martial arts are not the arts.
Oh really? What would you
know about that? Oh, I get it.
You wear a wig and you pretend to
be other people. Like by all means,
let me listen to you about social issues.
You get your fucking Goddamn car
to go back to your gated community.
When does she ever see minorities?
Huh?
When she looks into the front
seat of whoever's driving
[inaudible]
by all means Merrill.
Tell me,
tell me what society is like
from behind your gated community.
Um, somebody told me today
that it's, it's there,
this legislation right now going through.
I don't,
where does it go through the government?
Um,
right now I'm thinking of schoolhouse
rock songs, right? I'm just a bill. Yes.
I'm only a bill
[inaudible] off to the White House where
there's something something and then it
comes back to a bunch of white men and
they vote to see if it will be a low,
um, how I hope and pray. Normally
I wouldn't sing in public,
but I feel like I'm in my bedroom.
I have plush furniture
like this in my bedroom.
Looking at one with the fucking overhang.
Sorry to this go out again with the,
sorry, sorry. I'm sorry to each and every
one of you, especially the millennials.
I'm sure you're fucking heard about it
and you're going to Hashtag some sort of
me too. Me Too. I couldn't hear either.
Meet to meet too.
I also had something bad happen.
Hey, here's something you
can say in this country.
Three fucking meals a day may to
May to first world country me,
Joe, flat screen TV, Mito,
everybody dwelling on the
negative is fucking feminist, man.
I swear to God I want to go to one of
their events and just get up to that
microphone and just be
like, excuse me, can I,
is there anything good about being a
woman at any point during your day?
Are you like, thank God I'm a woman? All
right. What to add to step in that muddy,
that mud puddle.
Whatever the fuck I'm supposed to do.
I'm supposed to take my
fucking coat off, you know? Oh,
a little more respect for these feminists
when they care a little bit more about
guys, jackets, you know,
it's always a fucking issue
that they care about. You know
it.
In the 70s we were forced to wear clogs
and a lot of our mothers blew out their
ACO,
so gives a shit.
I'll listen to a feminist,
but not if she's white. You
know what I mean? It's like,
you know, I won't. Okay.
At the end of the day,
you were a white woman in
the United States of America.
What is the problem? Huh?
Did someone take away your
rosy for the afternoon?
Did they shut down the fucking
trolley down at the mall? What?
What is happening in your world?
No, seriously. All right. Look,
if you live in some honey
booboo lifestyle, right?
You're living off the
appellation. Somebody got
rickets in Lyme disease, right?
Husband never wear a shirt.
You know what I mean?
It is. Where's that long underwear
with the trap drawer behind the back.
You know what I mean? You know he's going
out when he puts on his best overalls.
Right? Those guys have it right.
Those guys know how to live out there.
If you truly want to get along with the
woman you've got to live on right off
the Appalachian trail,
you know you gotta be off the grid and
you just have to have no television. Okay.
And then you can slap her around all
you want and she's never going to know.
This is just how it is.
Okay.
You know what I mean? If you have a
dirt floor, like taking a beating,
it's not the big, it just seems like
part of your life. It's like seamless.
Where's the you could we ever did for
women as linoleum and like wall to wall
carpet. Then we lost all of our power.
Yeah, you've seen it. When
Twitter first came out,
women were just hashtagging
whatever you say and
no, somebody going to take a snippet of
that and put it on a fucking new show and
then I'm going to get in trouble.
Are you trying to say that women
deserve to be beaten on dirt floors?
And at that point you just gotta
go with it. Just be like, yes,
and I'm running for
president and fucking 20, 20.
It don't even get me started
with the gays in the hotels.
That's right. You run the most
hateful fucking campaign Ebert.
You don't wear the confederate flag, but
all of your suits, if you look quickly,
you have all the colors of it.
Alright.
And then in the end you just
totally flipped the whole thing.
You flipped the whole thing.
You have an openly gay guy is a fucking,
uh,
like sit-com level gay, you know what I
mean? Not like real gay, like TV, gay,
you know what I mean?
TV, gay. It's kind of like
when you watch wrestling,
how they enhanced their personalities.
That's what they do with good
gay people on TV. They got to just go
fucking through the roof with the SAS.
You know what I mean? Rather than just
having it coming out. Surprisingly,
every once in awhile, um, I don't know
what I'm talking about. It feels like,
what does this feel? And they
come along. If I'm a donor up you,
oh 10 minutes and 48 seconds.
There you go.
This is my world. This is my life.
This is what I do. This couch is not,
this couch is, feels like it
was made out of old coats. Look,
a couple of old tarps or some shit like
that. I hate, I was trying to be plush.
This was considered like right here.
This was considered fancy in the 70s if
I could just get this lapel Mike up here.
This,
this,
anytime there was a button that was sunk
all the way in it to try and make this
look plush.
You know even though it feels like
fucking week old bread that you lay in on.
Yeah,
honey. All I want is that legally.
This is what I literally have to do.
I have to fucking put the mic down here.
It just won't clip on in any fucking area.
That is acceptable.
Now the people at home can't hear
probably cause I clipped it onto the,
this was like the biggest lapel
ever. There we go. Jesus still going.
Got a bumblebee thought is supposed to
be like barely noticeable, isn't it? Um,
all right. You know what? I don't give
a fuck. Let's, let's read about some,
let's up some Phoenix news here.
Phoenix News, Ladies and gentlemen.
Let's see what's going on
and
greater Phoenix. You know what,
this shows reminding me up.
Do you guys remember when cheers went
off the air and Jay Leno tried to do it
live and the whole cast got shit faced.
Do you remember that?
And he had nobody to talk to.
Fuck it.
We'll do it live. All right, let's
look up Phoenix News. All right,
what do we got here?
All right. Update woman.
Critically injured in West Phoenix.
Shooting has died.
Uh, let's see. A woman shot killed
in Phoenix early Saturday morning.
Standard that standard.
Okay.
Homeless man beat cvs worker for sunblock.
That's a new one.
Suspect is designed,
is described as looking like
if Che Guevara fucked a lizard.
No.
Phoenix police arrest. Suspected deadly
shooting. What is going on out here?
Stolen truck from Phoenix.
Captured on speeding hot.
Why don't they have anything nice.
Phoenix wedding invitation
designers must serve. L, G,
B T oh Arizona. Here we go.
They don't like mark and Luke Martin
Luther King. They don't like the gays.
All Jay Jay's, oh the goddamn
gays. What are they gonna do?
They're going to walk around
and enjoy themselves. Good.
Back in the house where God wants you.
Phoenix woman,
21 accused of abusing three year old boy.
See ladies, it goes both
ways. Women also beat men.
Let's read that one. This
is always uplifting, Huh?
I don't know why this, there it is.
Alright, there we go. Okay. Phoenix woman,
21 accused of abusing a three
year old boy. All right.
My first question is a juror would
be like, well what did the kid do?
You know what I mean? Can the kid
walk? Is it big enough to make a fist?
You know what I mean?
There's no excuse to hit a woman.
So if this kid was punching on her,
you know,
cause it wanted to
breastfeed or some shit,
then I think she had every right to just
pick him up by his osh gosh bikash's or
whatever.
Push them right off that plastic party.
A Phoenix woman who's been,
who has,
who had been reported
missing earlier this month,
along with the three year old boy now
faces child abuse charges in a case.
Court documents says,
I'm not gonna say her name,
but I swear to got her first
name. Looks like Tequila. Uh,
21 was arrested Thursday on suspicion of
one count of child abuse in connection
with injuries to the toddler.
Oh, shake it off. Investigation
set in a court dog.
I'm just to see how far into the
beating of a child I could go.
Just how quiet this crowd's going to get.
Yeah.
Uh,
the child was beaten on its birthday
because it wasn't happy with the cake.
The suspect said, well, if
you didn't like the cake,
you're surely not going to like
this lit candle. All right,
I'm not reading the rest of this.
This is too sad.
I don't know what is wrong.
I take this back. This is fun making
you guys fucking really uncomfortable.
I'm enjoying the shit out of this.
Let's read some more sad news in Phoenix.
Let's see how far down we can.
By the way, you can feel the downtown
area. It's about ready to blow up.
I'm telling you, you got a great food
area down the street. You got, uh,
you got an arena is a cvs. Come on man.
I can feel it. I sensed this in
Cleveland and it turned around.
I knew it was going to happen in Detroit.
And who's kidding?
Who Phoenix is the Detroit
of the southwest. It is.
You just never had a riot because you
don't let African Americans in your state.
That's what, yes, that's what
it is. Who Says No to a day off?
You guys ought to be
ashamed of yourselves.
Yeah.
All right. What else? Okay. Local
headlines. This is, look, I'll,
I'll end it with this here. I don't want
to shit on you guys too much. All right.
Uh, valley traffic closures.
That's not exciting. Uh,
thank you for backing that
up, man. No, it isn't.
I did not pay money to come out and
listen to you to do the traffic report.
I can listen to it on my am radio.
Thank you very much.
County offers free dog adoptions to ease
the crowding. All right, let's talk. Okay,
we already got to fucking beat up kid.
Let's talk about abused animals or not.
There is my dog.
Where in there? No,
my dog lives in a house out here that
I bought for it. So go fuck yourself.
What was happening is the amount of money
that I was spending to board the dog
was less than a mortgage out here.
So I said fuck it.
And I set up like a Hugh Hefner lease
with my trainer. It's like, all right, as
long as the dog's alive, you live here,
rent free and you take care of it.
And I come out and visit whenever I want.
He's like, cool. I go when the dog dies,
uh then you know you either buy the house
so you believe it. You start renting.
He was like,
cool.
So you know damn well that dog's
getting fucking sirloin every night.
It's clear the dog's name is Cleo and
she barely remembers me now cause she's
getting treated so well.
Fucking house is nicer than my one in La.
Um, so there you go, Mr. Guilt trip over
there. Now let's talk. Let's talk about
this shit over here.
Let's talk about what you
guys do to dogs in this state.
What is with this fucking
advertising. Yeah. Am I on Netflix?
What happened?
Huh?
Coca Cola. We are so much
more than Cola. Yeah,
you're fucking gum disease.
Where's Nia?
She's right backstage.
She'll be out in a minute.
I'm fucking with you. She's at home
taking care of our child. Ah Huh.
Ah Huh. Not going to happen.
It's not going to happen sir.
Just like your dreams,
that is not going to happen.
Your dreams won't come true
in Nia is not coming out here.
Anybody watching that Texas
tech, Oklahoma Game. Jesus.
It was like no fucking defense
in that man. None whatsoever. Um,
by the way, thank you to everybody here.
Thank you. Thank you to everybody here.
That is, that has come out to the
all things comedy podcast network,
our first ever podcast festival.
It's been a smashing success. Did you
guys see when you walked in? We had the,
we had caddy shack playing outside.
You can play that a corn hole fucking
game. You can drink a bunch of beers.
This is what it's all about. It's all
about hanging out, getting fucked up,
listening to morons who don't
know how to read, do podcast.
That's what this entire thing
is all about. All right.
What do you guy, all right,
you still are about those fucking
Houston Astros going up two to one,
two to one against the La Dodgers.
I don't know who to root for in this one.
Cause you know I live in Los Angeles,
you know,
I know Houston just had that
hurricane, but it's over, right?
Everything dried up.
Those fans look all happy and dry when
you watch the gay me almost almost to the
point I was just go look
how nice this looks.
What was all the fucking
complaining about? Jesus Christ.
It rains a little bit and everybody out
in Houston starts losing their fucking
minds. You know? Do you think one of
them has ever sent a postcard to Seattle?
Those poor people sit in rain for
like 360 days out of the fucking year.
I will guarantee you not a fucking peep.
Not a peep from Houston,
Houston, Jesus. What is shady
city? That is, Huh? NASA.
How many people down there do you think?
I bet that whole fucking Houston,
that whole fucking hurricane.
I bet it didn't even happen.
I bet they just let some damn water go
down there when it was all only excuse to
kill the last few people alive that,
that were part of the,
the fake lunar landing
reenactment at NASA.
So they got rid of them
and uh,
what
else goes on in Houston?
They got the clan right outside
there that drags people to death,
which I'm suppliers didn't get an
applause break here in fucking Arizona.
MMM.
Yeah.
There was one other thing.
What the fuck was I talking about?
It was talking about no.
Then they got Halliburton.
Halliburton had changed their
fucking name. I know, I know. I know.
We're over there to fucking, what are
we doing over there? We're, we're,
we're concerned about their freedom.
We've got to get these Iraqis to be free.
Um, oh, I want it gets awkwardly silent
here. Um, oh, you know what I did at, Oh,
so anyways, I think I'm going
to be, I think I'm going to,
I'm going to tell you right now why
the fucking Astros are going to win the
world series. Okay? I'm going to
tell you why it's going to happen.
It has nothing to do with baseball.
It has to do the fact with that Jason
Law head is rooting for the Dodgers.
He's here tonight. Jason, lie
ahead. Grew up in Cleveland.
All right. He's fucked. Okay. Like
the second you come out of the womb,
that curse of that city just in Gulf,
Tim and everywhere he goes,
he's like the mush and a a Bronx tale.
Just tear up your fucking tickets,
la. It's over. You're not
going to win another game. Um,
no, I have no idea. I'm actually
rooting that there's going to be a,
there's got to be seven games.
I hope it'll be seven games.
Give me something to do. Um, I don't know
that there's going to be seven games.
Do you know that there's going to be
seven games, sir? Does somebody know? Oh,
because of the money.
You're thinks it's all about the money.
That's why it'll give. That's why
I don't give to charities anymore.
I'm done with fucking charities. I didn't
give one fucking dime to Houston. Okay.
Do you want to walk up to me w
up to your neck and water with a,
I live in Houston hat.
Then I'm going to give you money.
Yeah.
All right,
but I'm not giving to any of these
fucking things anymore cause that these
fucking organizations, they keep the,
I'm convinced that the most of them,
they just, they just keep the
fucking money. That's what's,
anytime you see a tragedy, just know that
there's a bunch of people going like,
I can make a bunch of fucking money
off of that Hashtag I care too. Right.
And then he'd give him $20 you feel like
you did your part. You know what I mean?
Like how much money would think Trump
collected before he went over there with
those bounty paper towels?
It just handed them out in Puerto Rico.
He must've made a fucking killing.
Yeah.
Probably spent the rest
on hair plugs and fucking,
I don't understand how he became a redhead
as he got older. I don't understand.
He had brown hair.
Six.
Somebody transitioning like I don't get
somebody like changes religions. Um,
not all of this is gonna
make sense? Everybody. Um,
you can still can't fucking hear me.
I don't know what to do.
Should I stick this in my fucking
mouth? Thank. Could you hear me
all right. How's that? Is
that good? Does this work?
Is this working for both of you?
Maybe if I clip this onto the,
onto the microphone. Um, Jesus Christ.
You know what this feels like right now.
This feels like when I was in summer
school and I was just staring at the
fucking clock,
like 23 minutes,
23 minutes.
Jesus Christ.
Why did I wear a sweatshirt
out here? Um, oh,
by the way, I gotta do I gotta do a
promotion? I got to do a promotion. I saw,
I went to a movie premiere,
uh, of the 30 for 30.
The nature boy,
ric flair is coming out.
Oh,
I have to tell you this right now.
Might be the best 30 for 30.
I have a fucking saw.
Um,
it should be not it actually it
is 90 minutes. It is 90 minutes.
I thought it was only 30 minutes.
So it was 90 minutes, sir.
It wasn't your dream came true.
See that everybody,
I'm going to start a charity for this
guy and a portion of the proceeds are
going to go to towards him.
The rest of them are going to go
to me in a new fucking drum kit.
I'll put his picture
on the bass drum head.
Yeah.
Each day, thousands of people are
dying of cancer and I want a boat.
If you call this number,
we can put a slight dent in it and I can
get the boat of my fucking dreams and
finally get rid of my wife and start
living openly with my mistress.
Please take the number down.
The first 300 people that call in,
we'll get a free tee shirt with a
donation of over three times the cost to
produce this tee shirt.
No one will check to see if the
t shirts were actually sent out.
That's the move people,
these two fucking,
this three moves to making
this country at this point.
If you want to exist in the future one,
you either grow weed in anticipation
that it becomes legal at a federal level
and he can get it out of
your fucking state. Cause I
know when Colorado, they're,
I guess they're drowning in the shit.
They got more weed than they got hippies.
They got more,
oh my God,
I got to tell you that the dirtiest look
and white people you're ever going to
see in your life
or in Colorado,
I can't imagine being a
minority in Colorado looking
at the white people there.
You gotta be thinking like, how the fuck
are we working for these people? How?
How are these people
running? Shit. I mean,
everybody just looks like they
fell into a vat of Po Chuli. Right.
You know, they're always inner tubing
and shit. They just live outside.
They're just, I don't know that that's
like in the Denver area, you know?
Then you get out in the western part of
the states and then then it gets better.
You know, you got the Illuminati is in
the rocky mountains, you know what I mean?
They make sure it stays
nice and cold up there.
So the body of their first wife never, it
never melts away. You know what I mean?
That's where they keep doing.
That's the code word. W you're going
skiing with your third wife today? Yeah,
but going on the double black diamond,
that's code for,
I'm going to fucking steer or into a tree.
Wow.
You know,
that's what's going to happen when global
warming really hits and all the snow
melts up in fucking aspen and Vail.
The amount of dead women that
are going to be underneath there,
the amount of first wives,
the before I made my first million love.
You know what I mean?
When I was at the college level,
before I went pro, you know,
I dunno. Sometimes I think you ought to
be able to kill your first wife though
because
there's like too many people on the planet
and then also can maybe like put them
on their heels.
That's saying you do it,
but just the fact that she
would know it was okay.
I think from where I sit would
have a really positive effect
on the relationship. I think the reality
television viewing would go down,
mmm,
I should do these more because with you
guys laughing, I won't get in trouble.
You know what I mean? It's when I'm
by myself and there's dead silence.
It stops sounding like a fucking around
and it sounds more like is this guy
reading from his own manifesto?
Yeah. The [inaudible] come up with
creative ways to get rid of people.
I guess the optimal number,
according to something that somebody
sent me is 500 million people on this
planet and we're up to 6.5 billion.
So I think that there's,
there's things that you could do,
like a stop rescuing pit bulls.
You should just set them free
and let them wander the streets in packs.
And then everybody has a cyanide pill,
you know, so if you get, you know,
if he wants to be ripped
apart by a pack of wild dogs,
you can just eat it every once in a
while. Or maybe you do that like, I dunno,
like there's some sort of incentive
for your family if you off yourself.
You know what I mean?
And I figure if you offer yourself
that's an even better way.
Cause then they can like prepare rather
than just have a bunch of carcasses on
the side of the road that'll
cause diseases, which is good.
But after a certain point, you'd
be, once we get under 500 million,
now you just killing the chosen
once the blue chips. Right.
They should have like an NFL combine
to find, you know, you gotta get your,
like every country has to get their roster
down to what? Down to a number. Right?
Like you're allowed to
have 100,000 people.
You're not allowed to judge
it by race, religion, sex,
or anything like that. Right.
And you just have the
best of the best of race,
sex, religion, all of that fucking
shit that we care about. Right.
You just have that cruise
ships now. No cruise ships.
That's not gonna work.
Cause that's also an
environmental disaster. I, I,
I regret doing that bit
on my last special. Yeah.
I never thought of all the oil
that was going to be seeping there.
So my new one is that you just let
him pull into port and then you just,
you just mowed them all down.
They die happy with his silly
hats in their flip flops.
MMM.
I know. None of that's right.
This is insane. A time like this.
Don't you think this
should be more caring?
Somebody told me today that they're
actually selling land on Mars.
Can I somehow get in on that?
Can I,
I'll sell you the whole
fucking planet for 15 grant.
You can get out there and figure
out there's no atmosphere,
then you're going to die. Oh, it's a
shame. I mean, it's there. You can see it.
Look right through the telescope.
I sold you that.
If you can get there and breathe,
it's going to be all yours.
It's going to be all yours.
MMM.
That's the way you know
something right there.
That'd be the first way of
how you get rid of people.
You Sell Land on Mars in anybody that
goes to buy it. You Go, okay, you won.
You got a a bit, a little bit of
land come down here to claim it,
and then they walk into a room like
Joe Pesci in good fellas, right?
You put a gun to their head. You're
like, Hey, wait a minute. What the fuck?
It's like, well dude, you
obviously don't want to be here.
You'd rather go to Mars is too crowded.
You know
I'm going to send you to heaven,
man. You can see all the planets.
All right.
I like it when people wonder if there's,
if there's life on other planets,
you know what I mean? Like why would you,
you know who gives a shit if there is,
you can't talk to them.
They're too far away. You know?
And what if they're
smart enough to get here?
Do you really want to wave your arms?
You don't,
why don't you just hitchhike down the
fucking highway and see what happens.
All right. I gotta do some reads here
for this week. I'm okay. Here we go. Uh,
oh look. It was oh,
Indochino in dope and dope.
Cito uh, talk about how every man
looks better in a suit. You know,
when I'm having gay thoughts, you
know, if I was going to fuck a man,
I would, I would prefer that
he was in a suit because
I don't want to feel dirty afterwards.
I'd like to feel that I was with
a gentleman that was raised right.
Last thing I'd want to do is fuck a gay
guy from Denver in his flip flops and
his fucking Hawaiian shirt.
It's probably be the last
read for these guys. Um,
uh,
right in doe is making it easy to get a
perfectly tailored suit at an incredible
price.
You can choose from hundreds of top
quality fabrics and personalize your suit
just the way you want it.
Whether,
whether it's for work or a wedding
or another spouse or other spin.
Another special occasion.
I can't read people.
Indo Chino has suited up hundreds of
thousands of men and are now the largest
made to fucking mash
mens wear brand in the world
play.
She'll order and wait for it to arrive
just in a few weeks. Don't go to work.
Sit there creepily staring at your front
door like that crazy Asian chicken,
that fucked up movie where she stares
at the phone before she pukes in a bowl
and mix the guy. Eat it. Do you ever see
that one? Yeah, it's called the audition.
Check that one out,
but not before you get a great soup.
Now Bill burr listeners and whoever
the fuck else they advertise with,
I love other ways.
Try to act like it's exclusive.
Like they haven't heard themself out to
anybody who could. The microphone can.
This probably some homeless guy outside
reading the exact same fucking copy.
You know, fucking empty refrigerator
box. Uh, listeners can get into Cheetos.
Best deal ever at $359
for any premium suit.
When you enter the code,
Burt, during checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price
for a made to measure fucking suit.
Premium suit plus shipping is free.
That's indochino.com Promo code burn.
Any premium suit for
just $359 in shipping is
all incredible deal.
I just felt like a rock star there.
I'll let you guys hit the high notes,
right?
Like one of those hair metal guys who
can't fucking hit the high notes in it and
he just fucking sit and nod
net yet with that devil. Look,
it's an incredible deal for a soup that
will fit you better than anything off
the wreck ever could. All right.
Oh look who's here everybody.
I'll look the next one.
It's all zip
recruiter.
Are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates?
Ziprecruiter is different.
That's why zip
recruiter,
uh,
with Ziprecruiter you can post your
job to over 100 fucking 100 up.
I just cursed to give myself time to
catch up 100 of the web's leading.
I feel like I have like
the w like a strawberry,
my hand that I'm just never going
to eat with this little lapel.
Like somebody saying something really
interesting. You don't say really
little fucking acorn with ZipRecruiter.
You can post your job to over 100 of
the world's leading job boards with just
one click so you can rest easy knowing
your job is being seen by the right
candidates.
Then ZipRecruiter puts its smart matching
technology to work actively notifying
qualified candidates about your job within
minutes of posting so you receive the
best possible met matches.
Find out today why zip
has been used by growing businesses of
all sizes and industries to find the most
qualified job candidates
with immediate results.
And right now my listeners can post
jobs on Ziprecruiter for free, for free,
ziprecruiter.com/ [inaudible]
one more time. Don't Save,
recruit until I point at you one more
time. Try It for free. Go to zip.
You fucking blow it.
The key is you got to make them feel
like the fucking the recording steer.
Take two. Come on. Phoenix.
You're better than this.
One more time to try it for
free. For free. Go to zip
slack.com/ [inaudible] right,
we got through it.
Oh and here's the last one
is another great one. Ah,
lets me undies. Everybody. Hey,
do doot doot me undies me on ds. There's
always one kid who doesn't do it right?
[inaudible] B undies.
I hope someone kills you tonight.
All you had to do was listen to me. I
don't have two mikes. I should have three.
I don't know this fucking windscreens is
soft as your tank when you were repair
of this fucking shit.
They make them for the ladies dry and out.
You fucking clam. All right. Sorry.
Okay me undies, everybody. Me
undies makes your butt me undies.
Your Butt will be proud to wear.
I hate that fucking word.
It's either your ass, you know,
but it's just to, you know,
I'm going to ask man, I just,
that word never just bought.
That's if you have a flat ass,
you have a button over,
lower back down to your ankles.
You know what I mean?
That's how I'm built naked.
I have the exact same
silhouette is the pink panther.
Big Head.
Big Feet.
Just fucking straight right down.
I swear to God you can hang
average Tizen off my backside. Um,
all right.
[inaudible] makes undies your butt will
be proud to wear and check this out.
I'm not the only one who loves me undies.
Listen to my longtime listener
and me undies enthusiasts.
George has to say,
is this George Michael,
did he write this from beyond the grave?
Maybe he wore the first month me on.
Do you remember that when he was shaking
his ass? Yeah, I think it will be nice.
I can touch your body and fucking
jerky. Bob in a bucket. Porta potty.
MMM.
Dan Get rested with Jeezy Busta.
Where my fucking cowboy boots. I liked
that guy and now he's dead. All right.
A note from George N m a bill
burr listener and me on Ds Fan.
I decided to try out me undies because
I love beef bill burrs, me undies.
Jangle I smile every time he sings it.
This reeks of being rewritten by the
advertising. What kind of man says that?
I just look out the window and smile.
Do you, do you just smile when you,
I don't believe a word of this,
although it's so easy to
skip ads in a podcast.
I always listened to bill's reads and
I'm so glad me undies has stuck with it.
Al Gore, right? This, this
is about as sincere as him.
If I told you guys my theory on why
Hilary keeps fucking losing, um,
even though she only lost once,
it's cause she has Mike
Dukakis is charisma and she's
isn't comfortable in her
own skin is Al Gore.
And you combine those two and what you
have is a dope that loses to an even
bigger dope. Um, Oh man, this
is a Trump state. I can feel it.
Oh yeah. Is he making it
better for you? It's too late.
It's too edit chance. You had a
chance at a day off and you said, no,
this is the fucking candidate
you've always been waiting
for. Uh, just coming in,
wearing his red tie and his fucking
silk underwear telling you how it is.
Alright.
Although it's so easy to scale.
Who gives a shit about
this fucking guy smiling,
looking out the window with
silky balls before me undies.
I used to buy a three pack of underwear
it retail stores until I realized that I
wanted to treat my junk to
something more comfortable and it,
and that starts with a
great pair of me undies,
cradling the family jewels to get 20%
off the best and softest underwear and
socks you will ever own for free
shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash
bird. That's me, undies.com/burr.
All right. I started to hype
something here. 40 minutes.
Everybody just like that. Just like debt
40 minutes that you'll never get back.
Um,
I thought he was going to be standing up.
I thought there was going to be more of
a show. I thought they'd be showgirls.
Um, I saw I might as well stand up.
It's so fucking hot in here. Um Oh,
he's standing up. He's, he's standing up.
He wants the world to know
that the fucking podcast.
What do you mean speaking up?
I got to fucking microphones here.
How much more can I speak up, sir?
Are they canceling each other out,
but the amplification or they both
polite? No, you go. No, you go.
We were both born in the 90s.
I want to offend you with my
yellow skin and your black skin.
Yeah.
I want to sit in this big chair cause
I feel like I would think that I know
something over here. Here we
are. Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to another episode of
masterpiece podcasting. Um,
wow. This is weird. Now I got in here.
There's a whole new sound in here. Um,
I hate that I'm at the fucking old age
where I have to cross my legs when I sit
down. I don't know what
happens. Remember as a kid,
you just fucking sat down and I got to
sit there constantly stretching out my
fucking hip. Um, this couch
was supposed to be nailed down.
Um, so I saw the premiere of
the ric Flair, nature boy. Dude,
I don't think I've ever fucking
laughed that hard. I mean,
I have to go back to like
a Richard Pryor special.
That guy is arguably one of the
funniest fucking human beings ever.
And I have to tell you something,
what I can commend about
that guy in this nature, boy,
30 for 30 that you have to fucking
see is he did not run from anything.
He owned up to everything
good or fucking bad.
They were sitting there
talking about like,
you know him fucking around on his
wife and he was just gone. Yet you go,
how long were you faithful for in
your marriage? He just goes one day
and he was like, I couldn't
do it. I couldn't do it.
I came home and I spent a day with my
family and I was like bored out of my
mind. I was in hell and it
was so fucking refreshing
to hear a married guy talk about how
badly he wants to continue fucking as many
women as he possibly could right now.
I know the laughs are going to go down
because there's too many women here and
every guy has to sit there and
act like he was, you know, like
probably thinking about it right fucking
now. I don't know. But, uh, yeah,
he talked about everything just being
like just all the women he was with and
then at one point they cut back to
his first wife. We calls number one
though.
This guy is a fucking legend
and she just cuts back to him and she's
just like, yeah, Rick wasn't a family man.
I was doubled over
laughing and then you know,
it definitely has its sad points
but he doesn't run from it.
You can say he's a bad father or
if he's maybe like an alcoholic.
I don't want to ruin too many of the
lines, but he was just saying like,
I don't know if I'm an alcoholic.
I knew I never tried to quit.
It was just one fucking closing
bit after another with this guy.
It's like I would close with that.
I would close with that.
I would close with that
and he just kept going.
He did tell this one story. I'm all
twisted up in my 20 fucking microphone.
He did tell this one story
to the crowd that was there.
He talked how we want night.
He was on the road and he
was out partying and he goes,
and I woke up with a couple of those.
I woke up next to an alien,
which is what he calls being like blackout
drunk and just waking up next to some
woman, you don't even know her
fucking name. So he goes out, woke up,
and it was an alien alien on one
side and an alien on the other.
And I looked down at my Rolex was missing.
So I wake the women up and I go, why?
Hey, where's my, where's my watch? And
they go, you don't remember. They go,
you don't remember? And he
goes, no. He goes, yeah.
Last night you through your watch
into a bowl of spaghetti and you said,
I got 15 of these fucking right.
Thanks.
This was just a throwaway story.
I mean, this is a comedy club.
This is a packed house. I'm killing
just remembering lines that he said.
I'm telling you have to
fucking watch this guy is,
it's like I'm telling you, they ought
to give him like the Mark Twain Award.
They're always given it to
like these, these fucking
people, you know. Um, you know,
they give it to some people that are
funny, but then other times they just,
you know, sometimes it's like that guy,
he's not as funny as fucking ric flair.
You've got to get him in
there, you know? You know,
they wouldn't know cause it's always like
the, uh, you know, the, the arts admin,
Meryl Streep and Blah, blah, blah,
blah. The fuck out of here. You know,
you think she could fucking be that good
and actress after a couple of Beck body
drops.
Yeah.
You know,
you think she could do the flare flop
and kip that keep that period correct wig
that she has on, I dunno why I'm trashing
Meryl Streep. I have no idea what,
you know why? Because she's always
getting awards, you know? Yeah.
Fuck her for doing such great work.
MMM.
This is the dumbest shit. You
know, this business works.
If you trash anybody, you, you
inevitably you end up working for them.
I can't tell you how many times that's,
I haven't gotten a lot of acting work,
but every time I've ever gotten acting
work and I'm in the fucking a hair and
makeup, I always get to skip
the hair part. Of course,
I go over to the makeup
side of the trailer.
Inevitably somebody comes walking in,
I'm like, Oh shit, I trashed that person.
I hope they didn't hear that podcast.
All right. Um, I think that was it.
You guys want to listen to some reeds
here for this week? Can you hear me?
Is Everything fine? Is this, is this
working? How has this been so far?
If you guys enjoyed this,
is this something I should do more of?
All right.
I've already have one guy, but there's
always gonna be one guy. Boring.
I didn't like it. All right. Uh,
on Monday I discussed silkworms and how
they take the spittle from a silk worm
and that's how they make a silk shirt.
Um, somebody goes silkworms, hey,
you ugly red faced fucking Twat.
You really think silk shirts are
made from silk worms. Really?
Jesus fucking Christ,
Dude. Just think about it.
Just think about that for a second. Bless
your heart bill. But sweet. Fuck man.
Get your act together and go fuck
yourself. You know it's funny.
Yes I did and I still do until
I was thinking like, wait,
well how would they turn
that spittle into thread?
But I also used to think that a
fucking, uh, I used to take a pony.
It was just a little hoarse.
I did. And I remember these people
down the street. They had, they had up,
they had a little pony and
I just remembered, I just
remember thinking, why won't,
when is that thing going to
fucking grow up and become a horse?
And I finally,
one day I asked my mother when I was
like 15 and she just looked at me like,
how did you come out of me?
Yeah.
What do I Google here? What is silk made
out of? It's just going to say silk.
Well, what they shouldn't call
it a fucking silk warm. Then
what is silk made at?
What is silk?
Oh fuck you sir. This shit I know
that you don't know. Okay. Oh,
everybody likes to feel so Goddamn Smart,
Huh?
What is silk made of?
This right here.
If there's ever a hunger
games, I'm definitely not
going to make it right here.
The protein fiber of silk is comprised
mainly of fibrin and is produced by
certain insect larvae to form cocoons.
All right. I was kind of right.
The best known silk is obtained from
the cocoons of the larva of the Mulberry
Silkworm. Wait a minute. Was I right?
What the fuck? Well, it
wasn't spitting it out.
I thought it was basically a silkworm
spider web. Why would it work?
Make a spider web built?
Maybe suicidal, I don't know.
MMM.
There's another way to make money off
of suicidal six silkworms each year,
over 30,000 silk worms commit suicide.
And I would like to buy a Tesla.
So please send your money in.
All right. Fat But fit,
uh, Billy, no roles.
Uh,
a study just came out that speaks to
everything you've said about being fat
almost automatically.
Meaning you're not healthy today.
There were a lot of people who say, you
can be in good health while carrying fat,
but that's just to soften the blow
to people who can't lose the lard.
All right. Anyways, thought I'd share.
You're not as dumb as Naea says you are,
but maybe still a bit of a moron.
Just kidding. Go Fuck Yourself.
I had no idea how much you guys laugh at
these people shitting on me. I thought,
I thought you were all sitting at
home as offended as I was going. Hey,
don't say that about bill.
Bill was my podcast friend.
Well, well, well,
well I guess you get to see all your
fucking friends are when you do something
live. All right. I don't even,
this is how short bear
my short term memory is.
I don't even know what the fuck I just
said. I didn't want to just read that.
You can be a fed. Yeah. Oh yeah, no. Yeah,
you're not. You don't want to be fat.
Like that's a big thing now to be
fat and be proud of it, you know,
and they talk about fat shaming and all
that Shit. It's just like, you know,
you should just ignore what everybody
says and you should listen to your heart.
Go and for the love of God, lose the
weight. I'm going to conk out here.
Ah, that was a cheap joke. That was an
easy one. I set you up, you know, easy.
I took you to the left and then
I went right. That's what I did.
That was the old misdirection. Yo
comedy crossover there. Alright.
Nestle cunts. Nestle cuts.
That's right. Oh yeah,
they are the ones. They're the
ones causing all the wars. Hey,
they had Billy in the mirror.
A saw this article about Nestle that
I thought might ruffle your feathers.
Uh, the line, the byline
says it all. Okay. Uh,
this year, this year is
Halloween confectionary. Oh,
this is so great. I have people who,
what the f what is of confectionary?
It's a white,
it's a candy store.
What kind of an asshole
calls it a confectionary.
You know what's funny? I got this
acting gig right now by the way.
I've got to promote the movie.
You got to see it next.
Probably come out next year. It's
called front row. Front runner starts.
Hugh Jackman is Gary Hart. If you're
old enough, you remember Gary Hart?
Yeah, Gary Hart. We went a little
ric flair on the road, right?
He Bang some woman and then
all of a sudden he couldn't
be president anymore and
that's how,
that's how Bush got in because this
guy was a good looking guy and uh,
all the ladies liked him. And that's all
you need to do to win the presidency,
right? You play the saxophone, you
hit a jump shot, you know what I mean?
You do something like that and then
everybody fucking loves you anyways,
that's coming out. By the
way, all you hear on a,
on a movie set is people going
copy that, copy that, copy that.
I need this, go over there,
copy that. And I get it.
When you say it into like a fucking,
uh, you know, you're on little,
your little CB radio copy that I get that,
you know what I mean?
But people say it to just other people.
Now just one person will be, hey,
can you move that over there? And
the guy go copy that. It's like,
why don't you just say, okay, it's a
lot quicker. Can you move that? Okay,
got it.
Copy that.
Those are the same kind
people that call a fucking
candy store. Confectionary. All right.
Yeah.
Hey, that's where you can, that's called
a callback. The guy just goes copy that.
He was waiting for the end
of the bit. See that? Now,
how does he know about callbacks?
How does he know?
Because Netflix has released
30,000 standup specials this year.
They're creating a comedy special
housing bubble over there.
Um,
come watch. The greatest open miker
is do an hour of their best material.
That's who they're down to at this point.
There's like everybody
has an hour special.
MMM.
I'm going to freeze myself after I die.
Don't they have that here?
The cryogenics right next
to the confectionary, right.
I'm going to freeze myself.
So then when they figured
out how to cure death,
they can unfreeze me
and I could do a bit of,
I can do an hour long one man show on
Netflix about what it's like to be in a 40
year coma. All right. Net,
uh, Nestle, everybody. Um,
by the way,F is for family.
Please watch that on Netflix
now that I've made fun of them.
[inaudible]
just scroll. If you can't find it,
just scroll left for like 20 minutes.
MMM.
Anyways,
this year's Halloween confectionary
will contain palm oil grown on land that
should lawfully be habitat.
Be Habit. I can't read this.
H A. B. I t a t
lawfully be habitat to orangutans.
I was always a rang a tank
like the drink orangutans,
rhinos and clouded leopards.
I don't know how the fuck that is.
Uh,
despite commitment to
clean up supply chains,
this is on top of them.
Siphoning. Yeah, this is, this is,
you know, a lot of times it's not me. This
is the sentence. This is on top of them.
Siphoning. I fucking screen just went
out. It's finally gonna make a point.
This is on top of them siphoning.
They do have water from national
parks that you've spoken about.
I guess they take water out of national
parks where they had agreements with
native American tribes
that have since expired a,
what's it going to take to
end Nestle's corruption?
Maybe you can take this up as your,
cause the way the first lady's doe,
um,
this is how you stop that. What'd
you'd have to do is have politicians,
politicians have to start earning fuck
you money rather than being grossly
underpaid. The fact that, you know,
as a podcast or comedian and actor,
you can make almost as much,
if not more money than the president of
the United States is fucking pathetic.
You know what I mean?
They should have,
fuck you money the second you become
present. Did she like, just be like, like,
you know,
like a pitching machine that's just throw
in one fucking heater over the place
should be a bag of money entire time.
You're there.
So then when these guys go, Hey, can
we siphon this fucking out of here?
You can be like, no, fuck
you. Well, if you doubt, uh,
we won't help you get reelected. I
don't give a fuck. I got fuck you money.
It probably wouldn't work. I don't
know. Sometimes I have good ideas.
Sometimes I don't. Um, so I guess, yeah,
don't buy any Nestle crunch bars
everybody and stay away from their bottled
water and whatever else they
make. Do they make thongs? Um,
all right.
Do you feel how the podcast
just immediately fucking
slowed down the second I
started reading out loud. It's fucking
unbelievable. Why do I do this?
Why do I do this to myself? What is the
shame is because I was raised Catholic.
All right. Accidentally made two
girls, my girlfriend. All right.
I like this guy already.
Hi William. The bald
big fan from Kenya. Oh, this is
a second language. All right.
Love the podcast.
And F is for family is amazing.
That's amazing that you can watch it
over there. Um, no, you should see,
go on f, go on the Internet. You can
actually watch all these people. You know,
you know whatF is for family?
I feel like captures the frank character
that's loosely based on my dad.
You know which one I think does
it the best is Mexico, you know,
cause they got a lot of fucking same
kind of people screaming and yelling,
temper. You know what I mean?
It just fucking works great. Um,
somehow that'll come off as racist, but
it was supposed to be a compliment. Um,
long story short,
I have had a crush on two ladies in
my college class for over four years.
Jesus Christ. This guy moves slow. Huh?
Now one of them is dying of ovarian
cancer and I feel like it's too late. Ah,
Jesus. Not that we care.
We Care in Phoenix,
Huh?
Yeah,
I bet you guys all
pictured a white vagina.
Yeah.
Fucking act like you guys care how you
try to bully me into your fucking phone.
He given a shit.
Yeah,
they probably showed that hurricane and
fucking Houston on comedy central out
here. That's how little you people
care guys are all about yourselves.
Yeah.
All right. All I, all right. I
didn't know where I am and this,
I don't know how you
follow a white vagina.
Next item up for bids,
a white vagina.
Mika did Mika auctions for serial killers.
It would just be like women's
body parts. Ah, we're so offended.
Oh fuck. All of you. I'll
steer even harder into it. Um,
did you hear that? They're going to start
having Jeffrey Dahmer Day in Wisconsin.
It's true.
They have an all you can eat ms and
all you can eat mystery meat day in
Wisconsin.
They're trying to change the perception
that all they do is eat cheese up there.
See we done grown in because
I'll keep fucking going.
All right, so this guy's had a crush
on these ladies for four fucking years.
But since breaking up with my
previous girlfriend three years ago,
I decided to not get into
another relationship.
So the whole time you with
this girl for three years,
you had a crush on two other women
for four years. I love this guy.
He's a fucking mess.
Um,
all I did with these two girls was
light flirting from time to time.
What is light flirting in Kenya.
MMM Wow.
I was going to do some starving jokes.
Yeah.
You want a piece of bread just fucking
with you. Ah, you're going to have it. Um,
he's gonna write back next, next week.
Dear bill, we are not Somalia or Ethiopia.
We actually have food in Kenya.
Okay.
Running water and skyscrapers.
MMM.
Anyways, all I gave you all he did was
flirt with one. One of them is the fun,
friendly kind,
but she's kind of loose parentheses,
open relationship and sending nudes types.
All right, so that's the one you bang.
You fucking, you double rapid, right?
You double wrap it and
the other is conservative.
The other is conservative, introvert,
virgin. But I really enjoy her company.
All right. There's the one you have
kids with. This is an easy one. Well,
a few days ago it was my
birthday and I had both of them.
And you had both of them. He just going to
stop there. You Bank both of them? Well,
she's not a virgin anymore now is she?
I had oh it,
both of them and some few friends over.
This is his second language
and I can't read for a party.
I had a shit load of booze and was on,
I'm going to guess right now the one
that he thinks is loose held her alcohol
and the Virgin Blue.
Everyone at the party,
when I'm going with,
maybe I've been in Hollywood too long,
but this can't be linear.
It has to make a left turn at some
point to spin us into the second act.
Okay, well, a few days ago it
was my birthday and I, okay,
and both over. I read, right, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. They came over.
I had a shitload of booze and
was on autopilot the whole time,
but apparently I had the balls to ask
the two ladies to be my girlfriend. Oh,
he was drunk.
I don't believe this is a true story.
Or did he watch some Kenyan
version of the Brady Bunch?
When Peter has two dates in one night,
a few days later I get a text from both
of them asking whether I was serious
about asking them out.
I'm now on a huge dilemma of choosing
between the two who I really like and the
fact that I haven't been in a relationship
in a while and basically forgot how
to be in a relationship.
Oh, shut the fuck up.
You remember exactly how
to be in a relationship.
That's why you don't want to be in one.
Any advice would be appreciated and uh,
okay.
And uh,
[inaudible] Dean [inaudible] which
is Swahili for go fuck yourself.
MMM.
All right. Well I think, uh,
I think you got to go with the whore.
You know,
if you don't want to be in a relationship,
but you did say girlfriend.
MMM.
I would just own up to it. Just be,
just be like, listen, I've been,
I was totally shit faced when I sent that,
but I have had a crush
on you for four years.
You always got to go with honesty
with women guys go into it. You know,
you always think you got to lie to him
and all of that shit. You gotta just,
you just fucking lay your cards on the
table. It's the best thing he could do.
She won't get mad. They might get a
little upset depending on what you say,
you know,
it depends on how graphic you get.
Where do you see this
going? I see you, uh,
laying off the edge of my bed on your
back with your head hanging off as I fuck
your mouth while watching sports center.
Okay.
That might be a little too honest.
You could just say, um, you know,
just looking to have a good time.
I would just go with the honesty.
I would tell both of them, dude,
you used the fact that you're
not in a relationship right now.
You get to hit the reset button.
You just go total. Honestly,
I would tell them exactly
what the fuck happened to say.
I had a crush on both
of you for fucking food.
I'm going to have talked
to both same time,
but I would say I sent it to two
different people and that's what I did.
And then just wait to hear what they say.
That's it. And if they don't like it,
who gives a fuck? Take you and
your honesty to the next situation,
I'm telling you. All right, that's the
best way to handle the fucking thing.
And then, uh, I don't know,
somehow you just tell them
what's going on out. Christ.
I gotta tell the story.
Here's a story for you.
One time when I learned about honesty,
I was in my fucking early to mid
thirties and I was just sick.
Elian and I met this chick,
she was like 22 years old.
So we get back to my apartment.
This lady's leaving right now.
She can't bear to listen to this,
right?
No.
So we get back to my apartment,
we start making out and everything and
she goes, wait a minute. She goes like,
wait a second. She says, where's
this going? And I said, nowhere.
What are you kidding me? I go, I'm
like 50 years old. And then you,
by the time you're 30, I'm going
to be like 86 years old. All right,
this is going to go nowhere.
So whatever you want to do sexually,
but you don't want to do with
somebody that you like you do with me,
right?
And then you'll never have a midlife
crisis because you got it out of your
system. And you know what she said?
She went all right. That was it.
Yeah.
They're not as prudish as you
think they are. Don't be afraid.
That's the number one thing you gotta.
You gotta go with the fucking honesty.
Do you like me?
No.
Yeah.
No. You don't have to be meat. You
don't have to be me. I like you,
but not like that.
All right.
Girlfriend loves my long hair.
I don't. Oh, go fuck yourself.
Jesus Christ. What are you gonna do
next? Go Up to somebody with leukemia.
My girlfriend loves my sick,
free body, but I don't,
I just love how you guys
have this thing with disease.
What is it with you guys and disease?
Why does it make you so sad?
It's mother nature trying to help us.
They should close down all the pharmacies.
Okay. And if you're lucky enough
to be disease free, you live.
That's what we need to do.
Tough decisions have to be made.
MMM.
Okay. So I've been growing
my hair out for a while.
MMM.
Since I enrolled in college. Oh Dude.
That's the time to do it. Good for you.
Grow your hair out.
Livia Steven Seagal years in your 20s.
Get by a sword.
Sit there Indian style,
meditating out on the fucking
some sort of bluff over there.
I never went to college.
Really? I never lived there.
What do they call it out on the compound?
The uh, the quad area, the grassy area.
Just try to act interesting anyways
and I'm about to graduate this upcoming
spring.
My girlfriend and a few friends convinced
me to grow my hair out since they are
all the hippie type. Ah,
that's not the cool long hair.
Skype probably goes to
the University of Denver.
I don't consider myself a hippy at all,
but that is the crew I run with since
I have known most of them since back in
high school and they are
all close friends. A couple
of them have long hair too.
I was open to the idea since I've had
short hair for most of my life before that
the long hair turned out
looking pretty good too.
My girlfriend though loves
the long hair on guys.
A few days ago I told her passingly that
I've been thinking about cutting it and
she immediately seems
really concerned saying,
I just don't think it would look good and,
but I really love how it is. And She
just dating you for your hair, sir.
But that she's only ever dated
guys with longer hair. Dude,
if you're looking to get
out of this relationship,
one quick trip to the fucking barber,
this is the easiest breakup ever.
And you got to go hardcore.
I get like a cop flat top
haircut,
detective mustache.
This is the easiest breakup ever.
Her concern kind of annoys me as she was
saying that she would not be attracted
to me in general if I,
if I cut it to me it seemed pretty shallow
considering we've been together for
almost three years. Yeah, dude, she
doesn't love you. She doesn't love you.
Get your fucking haircut and get
out of there. That's what I do.
I'm pretty fed up with my long hair
and everything that comes with it.
Not Hair trying, you know, getting into
my eyes cause yeah, dude, you're, you're,
you're, you learn something. You
know you did something for her,
not for fucking you.
Right. You don't like it.
You're telling you you don't like it.
She says she's,
she doesn't like the fact that you don't
like it. It's all there, sir. All right.
This is what you do. You fucker. One more
time and then you go get your hair cut.
MMM.
I don't advise you doing that. That's
mean. I just, I just needed a laugh.
MMM.
Okay.
Here's the last one,
everybody and then we'll own it will
be almost at the end of the podcast.
Hour and 10 minutes. Just like that
first ever live one. There you go.
All right
guys, lie on Tinder. Surprise.
Okay.
Hey.
Oh Bill.
I'm a 29 year old single
lady living in Virginia. Uh,
along with most other singles my age.
It seems I've had to try out various
dating sites and apps over the years,
but haven't had any success cultivating
anything more than a date here or there.
I realized this alone. My
God, this is so fucking long.
Ah,
lady. Maybe if he got to the
point you'd get a second date.
MMM.
That was a cheap shot.
Admittedly, that was a cheap shot.
I got anxiety and how long this was in
rather than admitting to the fact that I
don't like to read out loud.
I blamed her. I'm sorry,
and I'm sorry for your horrible
social life. Let's continue.
I realize a lot of this was likely
due to the fact that I've been pretty
overweight my entire adult
life now. Now I'm sad. However,
the last year and a half I've
managed to lose a 112 pounds.
[inaudible]
that's fucking awesome. It took me
a year and a half. Good for you.
112 pounds and counting. She's not
done yet. She's like John Elway.
She's getting the rings
at the end of her career
and
taken all that shit in the press. She's
finally living up to her expectations.
I love it and counting and counting by
changing my diet and literally running my
tits off on the elliptical
for an hour five times a week.
That's fucking amazing. Good you.
Anyways, last week on Tinder,
I matched with a very
cute 29 year old guy. Uh,
he initiated the conversation.
We had a great back and forth
comparing what podcasts we listen to.
I found out he actually lives in Ohio and
was only traveling in my area for work
for the next few days. All right.
That's a red flag. And he's on Tinder.
He's looking to get his dick
sucked. All right. That's it.
He doesn't want to know how many
brothers and sisters you have.
And what's your hobby? Oh, do
you like to cook? Fantastic.
Why don't you cook my balls in your mouth
as I stroke my Dick over here.
Um, brutal honesty. Women
like honesty. Anyways,
I know I should have called it quits then.
But finding out someone that had that
can actually hold the conversation seems
to be a real rarity these days. He asked
me out to dinner, but because of my diet,
I, uh, and wanting to be nice,
I offered for him to come over
for a home cooked healthy meal,
uh, when you didn't fill
them into the backstory.
Now he thinks he thinks he's getting anal.
This is how guys stink,
okay?
If we want this whole me too thing to end,
guys have to be honest about
how they think. All right?
He came over was just acute, was just
as cute and person as in his pictures.
The great conversation kept flowing.
I can't believe you just met somebody
on the Internet and invited them over to
your fucking house.
Please tell me you had a fucking
pistol taped to the inside of your leg.
The great conversation kept
flowing in six hours later,
we were making out.
We both had to be up early.
The next day he left with plans to hang
out again the next day after work we did
and ended up hooking up.
He left Virginia the next day,
but we continued to message pretty
constantly over the next week with him
initiating the conversation.
Most of the time, I swear to God,
this three paragraphs left and I want to
apologize to each and every one of you.
I want to have a benefit for all of
your ears having to listen to me.
Have to fucking read this God damn long.
Please call the number at the bottom of
the screen and a portion of the proceeds
will go to everybody's
eardrums in this room.
And also my dodge two
door hemi pickup truck
for 40 grand. Um, anyways,
all seem to be going pretty great except
the eight hour distance in between one
another. Well, yeah. Okay
guys never looked at a globe. Um, however
you know what, there's an I in
Virginia. There's an I in Ohio.
They must be pretty close.
Don't they alphabetize by a vowel
in the middle of them or something?
I'm all seem to be going pretty good.
Okay.
Except for the aid blahblahblahblahblah
nothing really came. Okay. However,
I just had a feeling something
wasn't quite right, so I googled him.
I'm guarantee you he has a family.
Nothing really came up except his,
I dunno what profile
than a few lines down.
I see an old wedding gift
registry site with his name on,
I called it,
I swear to God I didn't read this before.
You think this sounds bad out loud.
You should hear when I read quietly and
I just hear me stuttering in my brain,
I searched all the girls' names on the
registry along with his last name on
Facebook and Bingo all over this girl's
profile or cute pictures of a sweet
couple. The other half of
which is the guy that was in,
I was in bed with a week ago.
This son of a bitches married.
What do I do here,
Bill?
Do I call the guy out on his
shit and rip them a new one?
Do I send his wife a message
and tell her what he's doing?
He travels. All the women are gone.
Yes. So the guy that like, no, no,
no. Move on. Move on.
He travels the majority of the
time for work and I'm sure I'm not,
the first person has done this too.
He already deleted his Tinder profile and
our text message have only been PG for
the most part, so I don't have any
concern, concrete proof to send her.
I feel completely wretched.
Wretched.
W. R. E. T. C. H. E. D. Wretched.
All right. I was right. Jesus Christ.
Wretched. I thought this one you
like puking retching Hower right.
Everybody's got a degree in the room.
I feel completely wretched and terrible.
For the most part.
I unknowingly played in this entire,
I played into this entire
situation. No, you didn't.
You didn't.
Unknowingly,
if this is like one of the oldest
fucking stories on the Internet, also,
any dating advice for me moving
forward is also appreciate it.
Thanks for the advice and congrats on
that. Beautiful baby girl. Yours. Oh,
thank you very much. All right. Yay.
Oh, Billy became a father.
All right. First of all,
I gotta be honest with you,
you're kind of going Hillary Clinton on
this thing where you're not taking any
responsibility for this loss whatsoever.
You're blaming him,
you're calling him a piece of shit.
You're of the Electoral College,
you're blaming the Sandinista rebels,
everything
but you. Okay? You went on Tinder.
Tinder is a total hookup site.
It's full of fucking
like, and then guess what?
You met a fucking scumbag.
So
what I would take out of that is to
not go on dating sites and I would try,
I don't know, I would join like a
fucking sports league or some shit.
Like go play some softball.
I would try to do some hobby thing.
I know that sounds like an old guy thing,
but like,
you know the fucking
Internet is the Internet now.
If you want to go blow up this guy's
life to make you feel better, I mean you,
you can also do that. I mean,
I mean, I dunno what I do.
I just, when I fuck up, I just
go, I fucked up and I just, I,
I walk away from it. I mean, if you
want to, if you want to do that,
that's up to you. I don't
fucking know. I mean, who knows?
Maybe maybe his wife isn't blowing them,
you know,
let's try to blame as innocent wife now,
I just feel like in this
age of hyper feminism,
the way women always just stick up for
other women that guys need to start doing
this. So I have to stick up for this
complete piece of shit here. Um,
maybe, uh, maybe, you know,
maybe just the love's gone in the
relationship. They got the kids,
he doesn't want to leave. He just wants
to know what it likes to have fun again.
And you were fun and he fucking, you
know, it's kind of on you though,
because the first night
when you just hung out,
all you gotta do is look at his wedding
ring. And if he's wearing a ring,
you'll see the indentation from it. I
mean, you got to go a little bump up,
up, up, right, ma'am?
I don't know why I'm blaming for you,
blaming you.
I have no excuse for this
fucking guy. Uh, I dunno.
I mean,
what about George Clooney in that,
that movie where he's flying around in
the planes and he showed up and that
woman had a family, you
know, did he say anything?
He didn't. What was it
called? Up in the air. Right.
And he was banging that woman and then
he went to her house and he found out
that she was married and he was
like, oh fuck. He just walked away.
That's what guys do. They,
we just, we just walk away.
Women's start pulling hedges
out of the front yard.
They started putting rabbits
in the fucking stupid shit.
Like,
is that why we die sooner than they do?
Cause we just hold that in our chest,
the fucking pitch at a family and you
just carry that around for the rest of
your life.
Women get to get it out.
Okay.
Well here's the thing.
If he has kids and shit,
like maybe he's just going through a
fucking phase that he's working it out,
you're going to blow up that family
and their dad's gonna leave. And just,
just so you know, there's going to be
two kids crying with this guy has kids.
Does he have kids?
Yeah,
I know personally I would just
take the loss and I would move on.
I would just go like, listen, I, I checked
you out. I found out you're married,
you fucking piece of shit. And, uh,
because I'm a cool chick, I'm not going
to call you fucking wife. Go Fuck you.
I mean, you could do that or
you could just be, oh, you
can just say, I don't know.
I don't,
I don't know what to tell you.
I can't throw another guy under the bus
like this. That's a, so what you would do,
there you go. Someone in the
crowd. So that's what I would do.
Keep losing weight and move the fuck on.
Yeah.
Would you have to, this is what you
have to do. Yeah. You know what?
You got to look,
look at that guy.
Like you got to look at that guy.
Like when Columbus was sailing across
the ocean, he didn't see land first.
He saw branches. So he knew that
something good was coming right.
That he could exploit and cut their arms
off when they didn't give enough gold.
Okay. Allegedly, oh,
I go new evidence shows that he was this,
what was your find?
And it's somebody's scrawling
into a fucking tree. Um, yeah,
just look at this guy. Okay.
You're going to have to,
you have to take some losses on
your way to a championship. Okay.
You don't blow up the whole team
and burned down the fucking arena.
That's what you want to do.
Yeah.
Just know this. Take it as a
compliment. You lost so much weight.
You were worth risking a house for.
I Dunno. I got nothing. All right.
You know what? That is the podcast.
This is the first ever live podcast.
Thank you guys so much for coming out.
I hope you had a good time. I hope
you enjoyed it. I hope it was fun.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll
check in on. Yeah, on Thursday.
Thank you.
Good night.